just one day after calling kim
jeong-hoon
smart funny and a great person Donald
Trump is so upset with Canadian Prime
Minister Justin Trudeau that he's now
going to be punishing the people of
Canada Trump was interviewed by George
Stephanopoulos in the this was the same
interview we'll talk about later where
Trump ascribed to himself one of the
greatest human memories of all time
which was why he didn't need to take any
notes during that meeting with Kim
jong-un
during the same interview Trump said
that he is just so displeased with
Justin Trudeau's recent press conference
that he is going to make it cost a lot
of money for the people of Canada he
learned you can't do that you can't do
that said Trump speaking about Justin
Trudeau we have simultaneously direct
threats to the people of one of our
great allies Canada and compliments all
around for a brutal dictator Kim jong-un
who has his own family members murdered
in cold blood what does this do for the
prospects of renegotiating NAFTA which
Trump has campaigned on it's not gonna
help what does this do for Trump
standing for Trump sort of position
within the g7 which was already pretty
touch-and-go doesn't help and it's not
even totally clear what set Trump off
about the Trudeau press conference
Trudeau has been critical of the steel
and aluminum tariffs he said that Canada
isn't going to be pushed around by Trump
but that's not an insult right it's it's
just saying we are a country and we can
make decisions and we're not going to be
pushed around it's notable only if the
assumption is Trump should be expected
to be allowed to push anybody who he
wants to push around around and I was
talking to some Canadian friends who
said yeah listen I don't agree with what
is being said by Donald Trump here but
this is great for Justin Trudeau and I
looked into the approval ratings for
Trudeau and as of just a couple of
months ago Justin Trudeau's party had
only a 44% approval which for Trump
would be a record high but for Trudeau
is actually quite low and Trump
attacking Trudeau and threatening
Canadians is actually a gift to
Trudeau's reelection chance
and I don't know if that's actually
welcomed by Trudeau or not I don't know
if he's aware of it but he has now set
up Justin Trudeau to not give an inch on
trade deals and to have Canadians still
support him and doing it right
if Trump hadn't attacked Trudeau and the
Canadian people Trudeau would actually
take some flak for resisting
renegotiating a trade deal or signing a
trade deal or whatever Canadians now are
gonna stand behind the guy even if in
the short term he makes decisions that
might not be the best decisions for
Canada Canadians are going to be
increasingly willing to say you know
what Trump went after him Trump went
after us and we stand behind Justin
Trudeau holding firm here because we
don't want him to be pushed around I
don't know what the future is of
Canadian US relations but what I do know
is that the contrast between how Trump
is treating Kim jong-un and treating
Justin Trudeau is unimaginable would
have been unimaginable a year ago two to
three years ago and I think that this is
probably a good thing for Trudeau
yeah my sense is that this will
certainly backfire on Trump because
Canadians seem a lot more liberal than
us here in the United States and what
Trump is really saying is that Trudeau
doesn't care about his own people so
much because he's going to let them be
victims of a trade war sure contrast
that to what he said about Kim jong-un
at the summit which is that Kim loves
his own people you can't really make
that argument when the guy has gulags
and his killing his own people they die
who's killing his own family members
forcing famine and starvation upon his
own people and running one of the most
brutal totalitarian regimes according to
trump loves his people but Justin
Trudeau apparently is indifferent to the
Canadian people because he quote
insulted Trump
I guess merely by saying he's not going
to be pushed around this is a new era of
American diplomacy even though you can't
really call it that and geopolitics and
consider once again right this is what I
keep going back to the contrast between
our relationship with Canada and North
Korea Canada has teams in our sports
leagues North Korea sent otto warmbier
back to us in a coma
and Trump is friendlier over the last
week with Kim jong-un than he is with
Justin Trudeau Trudeau might actually
get more respect from Trump if he
decided to start developing nukes
forcing starvation upon the Canadian
people and having his uncle murdered or
something like that because that's what
Kim jong-un has done and it's getting
compliments for Trump it is the era of
the United States of America embracing
North Korea and Russia and Turkey while
seemingly deliberately ruining our
relationships with the European Union
and Canada and Mexico I guess this is
what they meant by Trump would be an
unconventional president or something is
that what we can say yeah it just seems
like he's taking all these positive
relationships with Canada with it you
for granted which you can never do right
you can never lay off the gas I think
Trump aswer argue though that you have
to keep your friends close and your
enemies closer that's apparently what
he's doing now they would argue that now
because it can be used to defend what
Trump is doing they would not have
argued that under Obama or under
Democratic presidents that's for sure
send me your thoughts and my question is
and this is not a rhetorical question
what the hell is going on that's my
question I'm on Twitter at D Pakman the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
and I look forward to hearing from you
with with some analysis as to how to
interpret what we're seeing at this time
today's program is made possible in part
by Warby Parker eyeglasses which I now
have two pairs of Warby Parker offers a
free five day in-home trial of their
glasses you try five pairs you see which
you like I wear contact lenses on the
show but I often wear glasses at night
and on weekends and both of my pairs of
Warby Parker glasses are great I did the
free at-home trial
I picked five frames that I liked on
their website they sent them to me I
picked the one I liked the most sent
them back typed in my prescription
online and soon I got my finished
glasses with my prescription in the mail
and I love this because when I'm at a
glasses store trying on glasses I can't
really figure out if I like them because
I feel the pressure of the salespersons
gaze on me I want to show the glasses to
other people I need time
which glasses I want to commit to and
the eyeglass industry is also controlled
by a tiny number of companies which
keeps prices very high I even know
people who have spent over three hundred
dollars for a pair of glasses but with
Warby Parker their start at just ninety
five dollars that's what mine costs to
try the five pairs and support the David
Pakman show go to Warby Parker trial
comm /t DPS